Ти маєш любити те,
з чим ти працюєш.
Я люблю, я ношу рюкзаки,
я їх буду робити.
Huru — це свобода.
Основна філософія та ідея — надати людині
максимально якісний і максимально цінний продукт.
Дуже люблю рюкзаки,
я їх все життя носив.
Щодо початку Huru,
це було шість років тому.
Мені подарували український рюкзак.
Цей виробник декларував,
що рюкзак — водонепроникний,
він дуже високої якості.
І я з ним поїхав у подорож.
Взяв усі цінні речі,
і з цим рюкзаком так вийшло,
що потрапив під дуже велику зливу,
і після цієї історії всі мої речі
повністю були знищені.
Це як така іскра:
я собі вирішив,
що маю зробити рюкзак.
Почався такий ресьорч:
я дуже довго шукав
той ідеальний рюкзак,
який би мене надихнув.
І почалось найцікавіше.
Тобто є ідея, є розуміння,
що ти хочеш зробити,
є навіть думка,
як це має виглядати.
Почався пошук людей,
які зможуть бути в команді.
Я познайомився з Віталіком,
нашим конструктором.
І просто зрозумів, що я маю дати,
можливо, якісь свої рекомендації.
І залишити його в його майстерні
на два-три місяці.
Там буде народжено той рюкзак,
який мені сподобається
з першого погляду.
Залишатися з неймінгом слова
«свобода» було трошки дивно.
Почались пошуки найбільш
вдалого лаконічного слова.
І на суахілі (це одне з африканських
племен) huru значить «свобода».
Так народилась назва бренду.
У той проміжок часу
я хапався майже за все.
Тобто будь-який стартап,
який був, мені подобався.
80% — це були невдачі.
І все ж таки я впевнений на 100%,
вони мене навчили більше,
ніж мої досягнення.
Після того, як ми зрозуміли,
що це все ж таки буде бізнес,
а не просто ідея,
ми для себе одразу зрозуміли,
що це буде рюкзак не тільки
для українського ринку.
Ми відтворили перший виріб і вирішили
з цим виробом іти на Kickstarter.
Чому саме Kickstarter?
Тому що, на нашу думку, Kickstarter
був і, можливо, є для стартапів
одним з найкращих медіаприводів заявлення
бренду на ринку і його впізнаваності.
Для успішного виходу на Kickstarter
найголовніше — це підготовка.
За нашим досвідом, вона займала
орієнтовно пів року:
пошук клієнтів, пошук журналістів,
пророблення реклами,
пророблення статей, пророблення пітчу,
пророблення лендингу.
Ми працювали там щодня
без жодних вихідних,
і це все була активна робота.
Ішли двома шляхами.
Перший шлях — ми працювали
з нашим потенційним покупцем,
тобто це була реклама
через Facebook, через Instagram.
А з іншого боку,
пророблявся медіапривід.
250 журналістів, скажімо так,
кажуть, що їм продукт цікавий.
Ми з ними починаємо
комунікувати щодо того,
що ми плануємо випуск проєкту
на Kickstarter у вересні такого-то року,
просимо написати про нас статтю.
«Ми — молодий стартап,
про нас ніхто не знає.
Ми, на нашу думку, створили
дуже крутий продукт.
Ми хочемо про себе
заявити на ринку».
Ми отримали 20 унікальних рев'ю.
Деяким настільки «зайшло»,
що вони просто зняли
окремі ролики.
Деякі написали великі статті
з фотографіями, з оглядами.
І саме цей медіаресурс при перших бейкерах [тих, хто дає гроші]
на Kickstarter створив нам пул клієнтів,
які купили наш рюкзак.
Помилок було набагато більше,
ніж правильних дій.
Ми взагалі не розуміли,
як відбувається технічний
процес виробництва.
Ти начебто успішний,
про тебе всі говорять,
а ти сам не розумієш,
як це все працює.
Ми, будучи на етапі Kickstarter,
шукали виробництво.
Це треба робити набагато раніше.
Та ціна продукту, яку ти зробив
на колінцях удома чи в майстерні,
кардинально може
відрізнятися від тієї ціни,
яка буде на виробництві.
Ти маєш розуміти,
як складається його ціна.
В ідеальному варіанті —
це проробити весь процес,
як мінімум, не запускати
його у виробництво,
але розуміти,
як все буде відбуватися.
Найперше виробництво в нас
починалось в місті Києві.
Ми готувались
до першого Kickstarter.
Але те виробництво фактично
не змогло виконати те замовлення,
яке ми їм надали,
по технічних можливостях.
Виробництво саме нашого рюкзака потребує
складних швейних машин з досить грубими голками,
які можуть витримувати велике
навантаження з міцними нитками.
Ми почали шукати виробництво,
яке зможе це виконати і спеціалізується
на рюкзаках або сумках.
Після певного ресьорчу ми знайшли,
що у Львові є такі виробництва.
Тобто Львів — одне з українських
міст, на мою думку,
яке якраз спеціалізується
на цій швейній індустрії.
На цьому виробництві ми відшиваємо
одну з наших партій для клієнта з Японії.
І протестувавши все
наше виробництво,
протестувавши якість виробництва,
протестувавши критерії,
які ми представляємо для виробників,
ми зрозуміли,
що ми залишимось на довгий проміжок
часу саме на цьому виробництві.
Ми маємо в лінійці п'ять
рюкзаків, три месенджери.
Окрім того, ми виготовляємо
аксесуари, які доповнюють рюкзак.
Проміжок між випуском
кожної моделі — майже рік.
Тобто раз на рік ми
випускаємо нову модель.
І випускаємо винятково тоді,
коли всі з команди
готові її носити.
Усі складні речі, так чи інакше,
максимально просто мають виглядати.
Нашій філософії
відповідає мінімалізм.
Такий індустріальний
дизайн в плані виробів:
вони прямі, вони мають чіткі
форми, вони мають своє лице.
Одна з моделей — це модель Н2,
яка найпопулярніша загалом
в лінійці рюкзаків Huru.
Вважається для нас фактично
еталоном наших рюкзаків,
тому що саме на цьому рюкзаку ми
закцентували головну лінію стилю.
У нашому виробі однією з основних концепцій
є використання винятково металевої фурнітури.
Ми з інженерною групою розробили
свою абсолютно унікальну пряжку,
яка є ексклюзивним
елементом нашого рюкзака,
загалом ніде не повторюваним.
З моменту старту кампанії на Kickstarter орієнтовно
за дві доби ми зібрали поставлену ціль.
Це дало поштовх для того,
щоб кампанія росла краще,
щоб рейтинг проєкту
піднімався вище.
Ну й далі ми робили б усе можливе,
щоб перевершити цю ціль
і зробити максимум для того,
щоб продукт був успішним.
Медійний фідбек з того,
що ми хотіли отримати,
абсолютно нас задовільнив на 100%.
Фідбек від користувачів
був подекуди дивним,
подекуди — дуже позитивним.
Мабуть, 20-30% ми побачили хейту,
що от «ви скопіювали,
от ви ще щось зробили».
Хтось казав, що це
китайська підробка тощо.
Так, безумовно,
ми були «нульові» в цьому.
Ми використовували
певні референси.
Ми просто зрозуміли,
що по-іншому не буде.
Навіть якщо ми зробимо
найідеальніший рюкзак,
і він буде виглядати просто
як космічний корабель,
знайдуться люди,
які скажуть,
що Huru схожий
на космічний корабель,
це значить, що вони
щось там скопіювали.
Якщо критика раціональна,
ми на це реагуємо.
Якщо вона емоційна — для нас це 20%,
ми й реагуємо на 20%.
Після того, як закінчилась
перша кампанія на Kickstarter,
ми зрозуміли, що будемо
працювати в цьому напрямку.
Ми продовжували випускати
перший рюкзак Huru H1.
І почали розробку другого рюкзака.
Третя модель,
ми її називаємо Huru А.
Цей рюкзак ми...
Особисто я використовую
для вкрай тривалих подорожей.
Будь-який аксесуар,
який ми випускаємо,
так чи інакше, повністю комбінує[ться]
з будь-якою моделлю рюкзаків.
Враховуючи той факт,
що досить багато виробників виробляють
пояси для підтримки попереку,
ми вирішили уніфікувати
цю історію і зробили пояс,
який можна використовувати
як месенджер.
Тобто достатньо просто провести
цей месенджер у спинку рюкзака,
і ми можемо отримати допоміжну
поперекову підтримку поясом.
З третьої моделі ми знову
запустили другий Kickstarter.
Ми не дуже добре
до нього підготувались.
Не було такого
пророблення медіабази,
не було пророблення блогерів,
не було пророблення рев'юерів,
і тому він прямо неуспішний.
Хоча рюкзак Huru A
продається дуже чудово,
він всім подобається,
але Kickstarter не пішов.
Ну, наш факап
на Kickstarter-2, нічого.
Краудфандингових платформ дуже багато.
В Японії існує власний Kickstarter.
Вони пишуть нам на імейл:
«Нам подобається ваш рюкзак.
Ми його побачили чи на сайті,
чи на якомусь іншому Kickstarter,
чи в когось побачили на плечах.
Хочемо цей рюкзак запустити
в нас тут на краудфандинг».
Далі відбувається така історія:
вони самостійно готують
повністю лендинг, всю сторінку.
Ми для них надаємо тільки
відеоматеріали, фотоматеріали,
описи, технічні характеристики,
фіксуємо з ними контрактні відносини
щодо ціни, щодо умов доставки.
Вони запускають Kickstarter.
Наше завдання — максимально швидко
для них відвантажити рюкзаки.
Вони їх відправлять найближчим
часом своїм клієнтам.
Ті, впевнений на 100%, залишаться
дуже задоволеними.
І за якийсь час вони
запустять нашу нову модель.
І на краудфандингу найголовніше,
на мою думку, — це репутація компанії.
Якщо репутаційна характеристика
компанії вдала,
то наступного разу ці продажі будуть
подвоюватись, потроюватись тощо.
Наші вироби,
рюкзаки чи аксесуари,
ми робимо з тією ціллю,
щоб вони залишились
з людиною якнайдовше,
ставали їй другом.
На сьогодні ми експортуємо
в 53 країни.
І переключення іноземного
клієнта на те,
що він має купити наш європейський
рюкзак, — це досить важка історія.
Перший проміжок часу становлення
компанії — це якраз було навчання,
ми вчились все це робити.
Коли ми навчились,
ми зрозуміли,
що маємо навчитись ще їх
правильно показувати, продавати.
Тому що про нас не так знають,
як ми про це думаємо.
Піар — це колаборація,
кооперація з людьми,
які належать до нашої
ідеї та філософії.
Зараз у нас свій піар-відділ,
яким ми дуже пишаємось і який робить
просто чудовий перформанс по піару.
Ми залучаємо ютуб-оглядачів,
які є популярними в туристично-
рюкзаковій тусовці, назвемо так.
Вони юзають чималу кількість
рюкзаків різних брендів,
вони знають, на що звернути
увагу, щоб спростити вибір.
Ми намагаємось робити з сайту
власний медіаресурс,
який стосується філософії
нашого бренду,
і намагаємось залучати тих людей,
яким воно цікаво і, зокрема,
які її певним чином сповідують.
От ми з ними робимо інтерв'ю,
і це прямо дуже круто.
Маємо нашу маркетингову стратегію,
ми провели дослідження,
чітко знаємо, хто є нашим цільовим
клієнтом, на кого нам орієнтуватися.
Це люди, не які купують масові
спортивні рюкзаки,
це люди, які шукають рюкзак.
І, відповідно, ті люди,
які купують наш рюкзак,
це як прихильники одного
автомобільного бренду, можливо.
Вони можуть купити нашу
одну модель рюкзака,
потім — наступну модель рюкзака.
Особисто я думав
(коли починався бренд),
що весь продаж буде йти
винятково онлайн через сайт,
через соціальні мережі.
Людина, купуючи наш виріб, має
до нього доторкнутись, помацати його.
Раціо клієнта на 80%,
і лише 20% — це його емоції.
Тому офлайн — це якраз
та історія, яка має бути нашою.
В офлайні ми представлені
на сьогодні тільки в Україні.
У шести магазинах ми продаємось,
і досить стрімко.
Укладаємо кооперацію
з магазинами,
які представляють продукти,
дуже близькі до наших.
Цього року ми чітко собі запланували відкрити
офлайн-представництво в Сполучених Штатах.
Наступного року при успішній реалізації
наших надуманих проєктів
(тобто наступних продуктів)
ми плануємо відкрити перший
офлайн-магазин в Україні.
Моя справа, як би це не звучало, —
це моя відповідальність.
Перед людьми,
яким ми надаємо цей продукт,
і перед людьми,
яких я запросив в команду.
Мене дуже мотивують класні люди.
І мені хочеться, щоб ці люди себе
реалізовували разом зі мною.
Їм комфортно зі мною працювати,
мені комфортно працювати з ними.
Ми дуже пишаємося тим,
що ми зробили і робимо
ці рюкзаки в Україні.
Завдяки молодим компаніям,
особливо які роблять якісний продукт,
який чудово сприймається
не тільки українцями, а й у світі,
бізнес в Україні буде
якісно розвиватися,
коли він буде будуватись
на амбіціях, на ініціативі.
Така колаборація має бути.